we are used to thinking of what we call
the news as a tool that can help us to
vanquish ignorance we will thanks to its
updates properly understand what is
going on and where importance lies but
if we examine the role of this
phenomenon with greater skepticism we
may find that it is as responsible for
blinding us to ourselves as for
introducing us to the complexities of
so-called reality the presence of the
news continuously albeit slyly
encourages us to forget entirely what we
actually feel in relation to certain
events the way stories are told
invariably promotes one particular set
of responses
this is outrageous
he is bad
this is tragic
she is a victim
they are repulsive
these verdicts may seem entirely fair
but only too often to an extent we are
bullied into forgetting they don't quite
we might in our hearts oddly but
authentically not think that something
is such a tragedy after all we might not
really care in the least about something
which we have been repeatedly pressed to
think is vital we might fancy someone
we're definitely meant to hate the news
quietly closes off alternative avenues
of investigation and response
at its core the news is opposed to
introspection it doesn't want us to know
ourselves better and compulsively
disconnects our emotions from their true
but often hard to grasp targets it takes
our nascent feelings of anger for
example and redirects them away from our
acquaintances or early caregivers to
causes that aren't remotely for us to
bother with it co-opts our fears to an
ever-changing roster of monsters
and thereby blinds us to what we really
need to be vigilant about before it's
too late
because of the prestige that we have
collectively accorded to the news the
hurried judgments of skittish third-rate
minds are allowed to determine nothing
less than our view of normality it is
almost universally taken to be sensible
to catch up on the news
rather than as is actually the case
for the most part extremely dangerous
and irrelevant
there is almost nothing we really need
to know outside of what has happened in
our own heads
and in the lives of ten or so people who
count on us
we would surely be made to feel
untenably odd if we decided as really we
should that we were from now on going to
check the news only once a week and the
rest of the time devote ourselves to
exploring the contents of our soul via
meditative reflection while pretending
to inform us about the state of the
world the news has become a formidable
instrument of self-forgetting
how to survive the modern world is a
guide to coping with the present it
explores why some key features of modern
life including capitalism advertising
mass media and the rise of individualism
can have harmful effects on our
psychological health